tonight is entitled how to build a
nanobot to fight disease so these are
nanobots i'm sure you guys all know what
net
are these little tiny machines that fly
around and shoot lasers at each other
and they cure diseases in your body
these particular bots are flying around
in your bloodstream with your blood
cells of course that's not entirely
accurate and this is what the traitors
would like you to think so hopefully
this Hawk would clear up a little bit
about what we actually are science and
where we're going and put these types of
illustrations in perspective so the
first question is why are we talking
about nanobots with Sophie and why are
they kind of the holy grail for medicine
in the future well if you think about
what happens when you put when you take
a pill or you get an injection or
infusion of some kind of drug what
happens and then from there we can think
about what these little little robotic
devices how can they achieve better
better effects than that so the first
problem with conventional medicine is
really systemic effects so this refers
to the fact that you get an injection or
you take a pill and you're essentially
bathing your whole body and this drug
that the particular drug that you're
taking which is almost certainly never
going to apply to every cell in your
body that gets to is they have a lot
I'll be focusing on here so you can
think with cancer drugs are often very
toxic two different tell cells of your
body which is why patients often lose
hair they're basically toxic to any
types of rapidly reproducing cells in
your body so this is one
that we have this point number two is
this bioavailability it refers
essentially to the amount of drug that's
available to your cells and then he give
it time so take it or get infusion here
in the x-axis you know it's the amount
of drug that's in your plasma in your
bloodstream so initially you see this
plasma concentration raised up but it
gets cleared then through your kidneys
and your liver and then you pee it out
it comes down and you have to take
another one so essentially you're your
dose that your body is seeing constantly
fluctuates up and down so you really
have to keep it within this toxic
therapeutic window as they call it so
it's below the toxic level but it's
enough to defective for whatever you're
going to treat third we heard first pop
cost is a big issue with these drugs so
as engineers like to do take all the bat
friend technologies make a list and then
see how many of them we can solve and we
create bacteria out of the weaknesses so
criteria number one to fix the systemic
effect issue would be something called
targeted effect so if we target the drug
to specific cell types whether it needed
or to local and we can cut down in
systemic effects number two we can't
stay any amount of time at one
particular fusion every day or week and
third on you can cut down and caused by
adults about how could we potentially
feed these criteria and if you let your
edge
and
kids are now
I
conventional drugs which is
but
here
now here
Arnold
people buy
poverty
this is a cancer charity drive
part
he is
fine
yes
this
domestic
the same size
the chair
entire
drugs
they
uses drugs
why
this awesome
answer
so there
diagnostic first diagnosis
and disease
straight down
sir
oh and
sure
traction
you